[Música]
[Aplausos]
escúcheme tal vez no sea una exploradora
ni una aventurera ni una buscadora de
tesoros ni tan siquiera una pistolera
pero estoy muy orgullosa de lo que soy
soy bibliotecaria es uno de los uno de
los diálogos que mantienen los
protagonistas de la película la momia de
evelyn y reik
me llamo silvia y voy a hablaros de
bibliotecas voy a hablaros de egipto voy
a hablaros de mí porque soy
bibliotecaria de profesión y arqueóloga
de pasión y como evelyn me entusiasma
muchísimo mi trabajo además de que me
apasiona la arqueología
como podéis ver empecé muy joven a
escalar estudia historia y bueno el año
pasado tuve a tuve la suerte de poder
escalar en egipto pude cumplir mi sueño
estudia historia como bien os digo
acudir al departamento de prehistoria
donde me dieron la opción de poder
escalar de poder realizar uno de mis
sueños era una criatura y comencé en la
cueva de antolín ya en urdaibai vizcaya
continua en acosté con alfonso al daddy
profesor de la upv y también pude y
también pude web para ahí también pude
descargar en en italia en la región de
grosseto bajo sol de la toscana en un
paraje preciosísimo y entre hayedos
vascos y
bajo el sol de la toscana y ya podéis
disculparme
gracias
pasé mi tiempo pasé mi experiencia
cuando terminé la carrera me dediqué al
mundo de la biblioteca desde muy muy muy
joven y podréis pensar que cambio no
trabajar como arqueóloga y de repente
formarte como bibliotecaria bueno
realmente documentar y escalar son dos
términos que están es que están
estrechamente vinculados permitidme el
símil entre una biblioteca y una tumba
egipcia son ambas son contenedores de
importante y valiosísima información que
bien gestionado que generarán
conocimiento generarán el que respuestas
el que el cómo el cuándo el de qué
manera porque todo eso
lo siento estoy nerviosa todo ello toda
mi historia la historia que pretendo
contaros hoy comenzó con un anhelo y
facebook y mi amiga cayetana tuvieron en
2018 el resto tuvieron hicieron el resto
en facebook me anunció que el instituto
de estudios del antiguo egipto buscaba
gente para su siguiente campaña yo
estaba muy ilusionada pero cierto es que
cayetana fue la persona que me insistió
durante meses para que pudiera actuar
para que actualizará mi currículum y lo
enviara como podéis imaginar el último
día a última hora lo envié la respuesta
de teresa bedman que es la coordinadora
fue inmediata fue a los tres días estaba
dentro de su equipo pero yo tuve la
desgracia de no verlo hasta dentro de
ocho días hasta pasados ocho días mi
email se encontraba en la carpeta de
spam moraleja no dejéis de mirar nunca
nuestra carpeta de spam
nunca se sabe mi pasaje a egipto se
encontraba en este en esta en esta
carpeta
pues os podría contar un montón de cosas
un montón de historias bonitas pero
realmente lloré y lloré de emoción
porque la primera es la satisfacción
personal es la satisfacción de decir un
recorrido que ha merecido la pena
mereció la pena mandar la última hora el
mail y finalmente yo estaba dentro de
este proyecto pertenecía al equipo de la
décima campaña del proyecto visir
amen-hotep huy theresa se puso en
contacto teníamos menos de 24 o 48 horas
para mandar toda la documentación era
era un momento un momento tenso me
entraron los siete males no os voy a
decir lo contrario bien estábamos dentro
ya del proyecto esto tornaba tornaba
tornaba bien estaba estaba contenta y
quien impulsa este proyecto el proyecto
está impulsado por el instituto de
estudios del antiguo egipto
por el instituto de estudios del antiguo
egipto tiene sede el madrid cobertura a
nivel internacional y está capitaneado
por el infractor el doctor francisco
martín valentín y por la egiptóloga y
fotógrafa teresa bedman tras de sí un
largo bagaje un largo una larga
trayectoria trabajando en tierras
egipcias muy interesante la verdad es
que es interesante pero dónde se
encuentra esta tumba es la tumba del
visir vamos a ubicarnos al norte el
cairo a 600 kilómetros al sur
encontramos el actual luxor que es la
antigua tebas realidad el nilo el río
nilo a su paso por esta localidad nos
divide en la orilla oriental y la orilla
occidental en la orilla occidental todo
el mundo conocemos los colosos de menor
el valle de las reinas el valle de los
reyes de ir el bajar y pues a quinientos
escasos metros de hatshepsut de la reina
de la reina faraón de la gran reina para
un trabajábamos nosotros en la att
número 28
en la tumba del visir amen-hotep huy
llevan diez años trabajando este año
será la undécima campaña han sido
numerosos los los hallazgos hallazgo es
muy importante muy importante es
tremendamente bellos son hallazgos que
han permitido al instituto de estudios
del antiguo egipto plantear datos
objetivos encima de la mesa
en los que el que arrojará luz sobre
cuestiones vitales sobre cuestiones muy
importantes en el campo de la de la
egiptología bueno y como ya os he
presentado el yacimiento es importante
presentaros al último turno las campañas
duran tres meses yo me incorporé en el
último con otros cuatro compañeros y
bueno pues llegamos en noche cerrada
muchísimo frío quien haya conocido a
luxor sabe el aro el olor no a polvo una
mezcla de polvo y especias un es un olor
muy característico te haces enseguida
nuestra casa era una casa alquilada se
encontrará en la orilla occidental y
ahora viene lo bueno el día a día como
que como transcurría nuestro día era muy
duro era realmente intenso nos
levantábamos a las 5 de la mañana
y i virgili el chofer de la misión venía
a buscarnos venía a buscarnos y a las
545 como un clavo siempre nos esperaba
muchas veces salíamos sin calzarnos por
la carretera y nos calzamos en él en la
propia en la propia furgoneta estábamos
a siete minutos escasos del yacimiento y
todos los días todas las mañanas de
camino a la necrópolis los colosos de
menor nos decían buenos días me gustaría
que os imaginaréis ahora mismo de fondo
la montaña tebana a un lado el templo de
millones de años de hatshepsut el
silencio porque el amanecer los colores
del amanecer los globos suspendidos en
el aire y a sus pies la necrópolis era
pura magia una de las imágenes más
bonitas que he visto he visto en mi vida
fueron pues
los mejores amaneceres probablemente
como os comentaba en la jornada
comenzaba a las 6 de la mañana según los
turnos según los equipos que formaban
francisco interesa que eran los los
directores de la excavación los medir es
con mucho cariño y respeto nos
organizaban y empezábamos a trabajar a
las diez y media aproximadamente se
realizaba el fatur el hamaiketako vasco
para reponer fuerzas y seguíamos
trabajando hasta las tres de la tarde
cuando recogíamos nuestras nuestros
bártulos y volvíamos de nuevo a casa a
hacer las labores como poner las labores
del hogar a hacer la comida el factor
para el día siguiente se madruga va
mucho y eso y eso y eso se notaba como
os he comentado en el en el yacimiento
es un yacimiento bastante de dimensiones
amplias se estaba trabajando en dos
áreas en dos espacios diferentes uno es
en la tumba
efe mv 2/3 sé que es un poquito
complicada pero es el nombre de la tumba
y además también se estaba trabajando
en el corredor de acceso al patio al
aire libre donde el trabajo era mucho
más intenso se tiraba de pico yo he
aprendido este año a picar a picar como
como buena vasca el día que todas las
mañanas a las 6 de la mañana cuando nos
poníamos manos a la obra francisco
theresa organizaban diferente en función
de las necesidades y del terreno de los
hallazgos del trabajo que se había
quedado pendiente del día anterior
organizaban los los equipos de trabajo
aquel día theresa me me me dijo silvia
todo y trabajas en el interior de la
tumba no sé si voy a ser capaz de
transmitirnos la emoción que supone algo
así porque en ese momento sí que estaba
cumpliendo uno de mis sueños y además
sentía una gran responsabilidad era como
entrar en una en una biblioteca
milenaria y empezar a leer a pasar sus
las hojas desde este libro de este libro
que bueno que lo lees una sola vez
porque la arqueología es lo que tiene y
tenía que hacerlo bien
el acceso el acceso era complicado como
podéis ver en las imágenes sobre la
superficie para el ambiente estaba muy
cargado hacía mucho calor y sobre la
superficie encontrábamos restos de todo
tipo y condición
en madera policromada de restos
cerámicos vendas restos óseos y
realmente como diría cárter cosas
maravillosas que podéis podéis imaginar
eso era lo que nosotros realmente
estábamos este es lo que estábamos
estábamos trabajando ahí se ve bien
estábamos
en ese momento en el momento que en el
interior de la tumba encontrábamos
estábamos en silencio simplemente
habíamos el tintineo de los palet inés
contra él contra contra los escombros
contra los fragmentos de cerámica contra
la tierra eso contrasta drásticamente
con el cántico con los cánticos de los
obreros egipcios que sonaban fuera que
estaban trabajando necesitaban motivarse
y yo en ese momento lo vi super claro
para mí todo cobró sentido por un lado
los madrugones el frío el intenso calor
de las y medio días los moratones el
cansancio físico el esfuerzo
absolutamente todo cobró sentido y
entonces me vi sacando capaz a capazos
la historia de egipto médica paseando
permitirme en la expresión si lo buscáis
en la rae no no está bien dicho pero
médica paseando la historia de ésta de
esta cultura evidencia evidencia
maravilla maravilla pero yo os estoy
hablando de una historia egipcia que es
lo que no puede faltar en una historia
egipcia una momia una o varias o muchas
pero de momento os voy a hablar de una
al poquito de llegar
tuvimos la grandísima suerte de que nos
invitaron a la apertura oficial de un
sarcófago intacto de la de la dinastía
decimoctava
en ella en ese acto se nos había citado
a las autoridades egipcias al ministro
de antigüedades al secretario general
del consejo supremo de antigüedades y se
nos había citado en la necrópolis y se
nos había dado si se nos había citado en
la tumba número 33 de la necrópolis que
se llama la de ameno pez de acuerdo allí
lo habían dispuesto todo era una noticia
que dio la vuelta al mundo todo el mundo
todos los medios de comunicación se
agolpaban en el interior de la tumba
todo el mundo quería sacar la mejor foto
ver el instante en el que el sarcófago
que en un principio se encontraba tapado
por una semana blanca
todo el mundo quería verlo todo uno
quería saber quién estaba dentro quién
que nos tenía que contar porque en
egipto todo todo tiene que contar todo
aporta y en ese momento que nos
encontrábamos allí realmente sientes una
gran emoción te sientes privilegiada
porque cuántas personas han podido
presenciar el aforo era limitado aunque
no lo pareciera en aquel momento porque
era un poco a la egipcia un poco a lo
loco se encontraba el equipo francés se
encontraba parte de políticos los
políticos egipcios y nosotras nosotros
la misión arqueológica española del
proyecto visir amen-hotep huy estábamos
ahí estábamos viviendo en primera
persona algo que probablemente no
volvamos a poder presenciar y llegó el
momento en el que los operarios destapan
el sarcófago un sarcófago precioso de
madera blanco azul dorado
impresionante y llega el momento lo
destapan y entonces es cuando la vemos a
ella creemos que se llama tuya es una
amalgama de vendas de lima
es una amalgama de vendas que están
perfilando su silueta que te que te
están diciendo estoy aquí fue una mujer
que vivió y soñó hace 3000 años y tiene
mucho que contar seguro estudios
posteriores lo seguro que así lo lo lo
demostrarán y así fue y mientras la
miraba atónita perpleja con esta emoción
que me caracteriza paso paso algo que
probablemente no hayáis visto los medios
de comunicación en el interior de la
tumba estallaron varias bombillas a la
vez y se hizo una oscuridad parcial os
podéis imaginar la reacción de la gente
miedo gritos y susto yo me asusté lo
reconozco el ambiente proporcionaba los
elementos necesarios para pensar para
pensar cosas pero yo en ese momento no
tuve claro y os voy a contar qué es lo
que tuve claro de claro a qué huelen las
momias las momias huelen expelen una
mezcla de olores una mezcla de
sensaciones
se perfilan perfilan un momento un
momento mágico entre el momento en el
que pertenecieron y el momento en el que
son rescatadas esos dos momentos se
tocan y si los aves tienen sensibilidad
suficiente lo disfrutas como un momento
único en tu vida sabes a qué huele las
momias os lo voy a decir huelen a
biblioteca huele a tumba egipcia huelen
a sueños cumplidos muchas gracias
gracias
[Aplausos]